you said earlier that if someone can
have this crisis sort of the dark night
of the soul in their 20s that's great
and then maybe move up from there
but for everyone that doesn't always
happen so what if someone's in their 30s
40s 50s and Beyond and they have this
sort of breakdown and they've realized
they've never really been self-aware
there's still time
what would you tell them because now of
course they're expected to pull it
together and be part of society and you
can't flounder and be Moody as a as a
middle-aged person but what would you
tell them everybody has a starting point
well I think if there's you know
obviously my our situations are all
unique but one of the things I had admit
was that I didn't really have the
solution I think there's a there's a
strong culture in the Western world of
you know I did it my way the strength is
within you did you know and but I I
actually I had to say to myself I don't
have I had to find another way of living
daily life these spiritual principles
and to do that though
it takes a certain amount of honesty it
takes in fact a gut-level degree of self
honesty to really be willing to do that
and I think it's it's a sacrifice you
know it's a to make that so it's like
okay if you're in your 40s and you've
spent 40 years developing your habits
you know implanting your neural brain
yeah you know your neural brain pathways
that they're not fixed but they're
pretty well run in it's going to be hard
for you to break out of those habits and
frankly you may not be able to do it
with the the the way that you have
always done things it's like you know
that all picking things up by the
bootstraps you know the brain can't sort
out the brain I had to come up with new
habits new ways of doing things
they were different to the way I see
that I saw the world they jart with me
they they they they contradicted a lot
of things that I believed to be true
about the
what I'm saying is that willingness to
take on a new way of doing things was so
important as long as I couldn't
magically and the brain is not computer
ice thing for years the brains a
computer it's not the brain is is just a
very complicated heart you know it's
just it's it's a it's an emotional it's
a huge emotional thing with this little
layer of rationality on top this totally
at mercy from any emotions that are
strong enough and that for decades of
emotions and emotional habits cannot be
suddenly come over by this tiny little
bit of rational mind you know for me I
had to find a new way of approaching the
fundamental issues of life and I had to
be willing to do that and that
willingness was was key I think in it
and it can seem like a destruction of
self but the thing is if that selves
failed what you're going to do well how
do you how do you serve it the self
cannot service the self you know life
servicing a car the self cannot service
the south need to bring in something
else and that's what I had to do I had
to it wasn't like some big insight or
look look look I'm ready to change it
was I had to I felt I had no choice but
to try a different way so self-awareness
you think is really important especially
to propel someone to their next level
because if things are still so status
quo then nothing's really ever gonna be
let me the thing is we have so many I
don't know if this just but the papers
love to tell stories about successful
people who screw up so does that give a
false image that you can be successful
and screw up I think it might do maybe
there are people are just so talented or
so lucky that they can screw it
repeatedly but still have some success
I'm not one of those people I mean I'm
not even even anywhere near that level
what I mean is I'm not one of those
people who can have any level of success
if I don't deal with my own flaws and
and don't have some self-awareness so I
think there's like if you like me and
you
this thing then you know you can't be
like Britney Spears I keep on using
there's an example who can who can shave
her head and you know go crazy and and
still then have a successful music
career afterwards you know that wouldn't
with me I can't shave my head I can't go
crazy I just have to keep on Tron
develop personally develop
professionally and see what happens next
you